♪ ♪
>> Greg: YOU WANT SOME GOOD
NEWS?
IT STARTS OUT BAD.
YESTERDAY WE MENTIONED THE
COLD-BLOODED MURDERS OF TWO
SENIORS NAMED PAUL AND LIDIA.
THEY VISITED THEIR SON’S GRAVE
AT DELAWARE’S VETERANS MEMORIAL
CEMETERY LAST MONTH THEY WERE
SHOT DEAD BY A LONE GUNMAN
THERE.
AMID THE PANDEMIC, THE STORY
WENT LARGELY IGNORED.
PAUL WAS AN ARMY VET, THE LIDIA
WAS A LOVING MOM AND THEY HAD
THREE SONS, SIX GRANDKIDS AND
TWO GREAT-GRANDCHILDREN.
I BET YOU DIDN’T HEAR ABOUT THEM
UNTIL YOU WATCHED "THE FIVE."
I FOUND OUT THAT A STRANGER,
CHRIS MILLER, A MEMBER OF THE
HONOR GUARD WHO PERFORMED AT THE
CEMETERY SET UP A GOFUNDME PAGED
UP THE FAMILY PAY THE FUNERAL
COSTS SO I FIGURED WHY NOT HELP.
LAST NIGHT THE DONATIONS CLIMBED
FROM THOUSANDS TO OVER 90 GRAND.
I’M NOT BLOWING MY HORN.
I AM BLOWING YOUR HORN.
THOSE WHO WATCHED THE SHOW LAST
NIGHT AND CHOSE TO HELP, YOU ARE
THE BEST.
WHAT’S THE LESSON?
THE PEOPLE WANT TO HELP.
IF YOUR CAR BREAKS DOWN IN
TEXAS, THERE’S GOT TO BE FOUR
PICKUP TRUMPS PULLING OVER TO
HELP.
IF YOU SLIP ON A SIDEWALK,
PEDESTRIANS WILL HELP YOU.
WHEN THERE IS A DISASTER PEOPLE
PITCH IN.
IT’S VITAL TO NOTE AS WE ARE
CAUGHT IN A WHIRLWIND OF DEMONIC
SMEARS WHEN ANCHORS OF NETWORK
SAY ALL OF AMERICA IS
IRREDEEMABLY RACIST, WHEN WE
HAVE POLITICIANS WHO PREFER
VENGEANCE OVER CONVERSATION.
WHEN WE HAVE ANGRY ACTIVISTS WHO
THINK IT’S LEGIT TO DESTROY
SOMEBODY’S BUSINESS, WHEN WE
HAVE MOBS WHO BEAT PEOPLE DOWN
RATHER THAN HELP THEM UP.
WE NEED TO REMIND THOSE PEOPLE
WANT DECENT PEOPLE ACTUALLY DO.
WE ASSIST.
WE SACRIFICE.
WHO ELSE NEEDS HELP?
OFFICER SHANE NICK ALONENESS,
AGE 29 WAS SHOT IN THE HEAD
DURING RECENT VEGAS PROTEST.
SHEA IS PARALYZED, UNABLE TO
SPEAK.
THAT’S THE THING ABOUT HELPING
OUT, IT’S EASY.
IT’S ADDICTIVE AND IT FEELS
GREAT BECAUSE IT IS.
SO DANA, OFFICER MIKILONIS.
IT’S UP TO 155,000.
HE’S GOING TO REQUIRE LIFELONG
CARE I DON’T.
PEOPLE SHOULD SEEK OUT OFFICER
MIKALONIS’ PAGE.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT REMARKABLE IS IT’S AN HONOR
TO BE ON THIS SHOW, IT’S A REAL
PRIVILEGE TO BE ON THE SHOW.
WE ARE IN OUR TENTH YEAR AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN I AM ALWAYS
BLOWN AWAY BY THE GENEROSITY AND
LOVE THAT OUR VIEWERS SHOWED ONE
ANOTHER AND WE REALLY, REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
>> Greg: YEAH.
EVEN THOUGH SOME OF OUR VIEWERS
GET MAD AT YOU, JUAN, YOU HAVE
TO ADMIT IF YOUR CAR BROKE DOWN
THEY WOULD PULL OVER AND HELP
YOU.
>> Juan: I THINK THEY WOULD DO
THE SAME FOR YOU GREG, EVEN
THOUGH THEY GET MAD ABOUT YOU.
WE HAVE IS AMERICA STANDING UP
AND I LOVE TO SEE AMERICANS
REACH OUT AND GIVE SOME COMFORT
TO A GRIEVING FAMILY IN EITHER
SITUATION AND TO TAKE, AMERICANS
RISE UP OUT OF A BAD SITUATION
AND MAKE GOOD OF IT AND I THINK
THAT’S WONDERFUL AND IT’S GREAT
FOR THE FIVE FAMILY.
I THINK IT’S GOT TO EXTEND TO
ALL THE DAMAGE THAT WE SEE DONE
TO PEOPLE.
I DON’T CARE WHO DOES SUPPORT
YOU HAVE EMPATHY AND LOVING YOUR
HEART, YOU MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
YOU DO MAKE A DIFFERENCE,
AMERICA.
>> Greg: DAGEN, THIS GOFUNDME
THING IS GREAT.
THEY MAKE SOME MONEY OFF OF IT
BUT IT MAKES IT SO MUCH EASIER
TO HELP PEOPLE.
>> Dagen: IT DOES AND REACH
OUT TO PEOPLE INSTANTLY.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
"THE FIVE" VIEWERS WHO SUPPORTED
ME DURING MY MOTHER’S ILLNESS
AND DEATH.
PEOPLE LITERALLY, THERE IS A
WOMAN WHO TWEETED ME SEVERAL
TIMES A WEEK IF NOT DAILY
THROUGHOUT MY MOMS LUNG CANCER
BATTLE AND AFTER HER DEATH, SHE
STILL DOESN’T.
IT.
ALL SHE TWEETS ME IS
Xs AND Os BUT IT SHOWS
KINDNESS AND A GENEROSITY OF
SPIRIT AND WHO WE REALLY ARE.
WHO WE ARE AS A NATION.
>> Greg: JESSE, I THINK IT’S
GREAT, WE REALIZE HUMANS ARE
NATURALLY INCLINED TO HELP OTHER
HUMANS, EVEN YOU, JESSE.
>> Jesse: IT’S FUNNY THAT YOU
SAY THAT BECAUSE YESTERDAY I
WASN’T GOING TO DONATE BUT THEN
I SAW THAT WE WERE DOING THE
SEGMENT TODAY I HAD TO DONATE
BECAUSE I WANTED TO TELL
EVERYBODY ON TELEVISION THAT I
DONATED.
THAT MAKES ME FEEL REALLY GOOD.
AND GREG, I HAVE TO SAY YOU DID
DO A REALLY GOOD THING AND IT
REALLY STANDS OUT BECAUSE YOU
RARELY DO SUCH GOOD THINGS.
I WANT TO COMPLIMENT YOU.
>> Greg: THAT’S TRUE.
>> Jesse: I THINK YOU’RE
ENTERING A NEW PHASE IN YOUR
LIFE, JUST LIKE THE COUNTRY IS
GOING THROUGH PHASES.
GREG IS GOING THROUGH PHASES.
MAYBE THIS IS YOUR BOROQUE
PERIOD.
MY WIFE SAYS YOU LOOK THIN,